the terror caused by these attacks
cannot be overstated their life's work
and all their possessions blown away in
an instant
by chance the family weren't here
and they're still very much in shock i'm
so sorry
this is the kitchen
that is utterly destroyed the russian
troops have stopped short of entering
kiev but they're wreaking horror inside
the homes of its residents from afar
devastation here the windows just blew
in he says any stalling of the russian
offensive means nothing to those at the
end of their missiles
he pauses he can't quite find strong
enough phrases for what his family's
going through right now
[Music]
this is an atrocity for which no judge
would ever find any justification
it's madness he says
and few right now would disagree with
him
on the other side of the street his
neighbors took the full brunt of the
blast the front gardens now a 15-foot
deep crater this has landed right in the
middle of a very very suburban area all
around here are residential homes
many of which
were still occupied and this is exactly
what the international criminal court is
investigating a potential war
crime we're shown the remnants of the
missile they're desperate here to ensure
those who attack them are held
accountable
the blast has made this home's front
entrance impassable
so we're taken in through one of the
damaged windows
the russian soldiers seem to have been
held back from encircling the main city
but they're now resorting to long-range
attacks which are indiscriminate and
terrifying
this is just utterly a whole family
house just
reduced to ruins and rubble every room
is like this with
holes blasted through it
how safe do you feel
living here now
of course i don't feel safe here he says
where is safe now
there's shooting bombing rockets hitting
us we live here but we know it's very
dangerous here
few feel safe in a capital where random
strikes can happen anywhere anytime
ukrainian defenses have somehow held off
the russian forces from their main city
but they can't stop the horror unfolding
here
[Laughter]
this is the raw pain of knowing someone
you love has gone and your life will
never be the same
it's heartbreak being replayed all over
ukraine
[Laughter]
this bombardment may be a desperate
attempt to break the capital spirit
russian troops look like they're
struggling to complete their
strangulation of the capital anytime
soon
but for both sides kiev is everything
and that might mean more erratic and
wretched war actions ahead
alex crawford sky news in kiev